ces affiches ont été apposées ce matin
sur les grilles de la maison de la mère
et de l'enfant à besançon par les
militants du mouvement pour la liberté
de l'avortement et de la contraception
ils étaient une vingtaine à occuper
depuis hier 19 heures l'entrée du
service de gynécologie et obstétrique à
10h45 ce matin les forces de police les
ont fait évacuer à la demande du
directeur et du conseil d'administration
de l'hôpital qui estimait que le travail
du service était entravé il n'y a pas eu
d'incident sérieux quelques manifestants
ont été emmenés à l'hôtel de police pour
vérification d'identité
elle est finie et nous l'avons
accompagné je pense que là il ya une
différence essentielle de ce pas elle
est venue de mangue et au dr colette de
l'avorter puisqu'il est gynécologue
elle avait un certificat d'un médecin
généraliste qui l'avait examiné
la position la contraception d'accord et
nous sommes toujours prêts à la faire et
je suis déjà depuis au moins cinq ans
l'orthogénie smet annoncé à l'entrée du
service ne voulons qu'elle dr colette
qu'on craigne que
avorter une femme ce n'est pas céder à
la pression de quelques uns c'est
simplement
répondre à la demande d'une femme qui
est libre de décider de sa maternité
ceci la santé de cette femme est
gravement compromise
nous prendrons la décision d'avorter
vous vous la protéger cette santé la
même façon si nous avons la quasi
certitude que l'enfant annette sera un
enfant gravement anormal et nous en
avons les moyens nous avons été les
premiers en france avec l'équipe de
bouées à paris et l'équipe de lyon a
pratiqué les amis aux synthèses précoce
à ce moment là également nous prendrons
la décision d'interrompre cette
grossesse faut bien dire de tuer ce
foetus avoir un enfant c'est une
conséquence mais finalement je pense que
ce n'est pas la première chose dans
l'acte d'amour donc si la femme veulent
avoir un an qu'elle puisse la voir qu'on
lui donne toutes les possibilités
d'avoir autant d'enfants que l'envié de
les élever mais s'ils ne désirent pas en
avoir vois pas pourquoi la société
actuelle voire plusieurs à avoir des
enfants et elle doit l'obliger à ozoir
doigt les élever avec beaucoup de
difficultés et on ne lui demande pas son
avis mais c'est simple vous triomphez
rechange le voudrions qu'il y ait une
autre loi qui permette aux femmes
d'avoir des enfants
quand elles veulent autant qu'elle en
veut et si exemple je ne vais pas
prendre une décision à 10 heures du soir
sous la pression des événements quand
même pas un même s'il y avait des
matraques